90 kilos of cocaine were found in the
trunk of a vehicle at a border patrol
checkpoint
the markings of the cocaine packages
were
the scorpion this was the label for
amado and the juarez cartel
if this guy was connected to the juarez
cartel i knew this was the break i
needed
come with me
i said my name is sal
i said what's your name he says i'm rudy
i told him i said listen you're in a lot
of trouble
the only way you're gonna get out of
this is by telling me what you know
about this organization
he tells me i can't cooperate with you
they're going to kill me
and i said they're going to kill you
anyways if i let you go because right
here you lost a lot of their drugs
he says if i give you information about
the cartel can you go and protect me
so i said listen you want my help you
need to go and give me information
that's going to be worthwhile
[Music]
he knew that he was in a no-win
situation
[Music]
he says the cartel is sending somebody
from juarez to make sure that everything
runs smooth on this load
they call him el wapo he's one of the
shot callers for the cartel
trying to penetrate any criminal
organization the only way to do it is to
actually do undercover work
so i am thinking wow this is going to be
a
great
opportunity to get somebody higher in
the cartel by role playing as an
undercover agent
i asked him i said how can i be a part
of this
he goes we need a driver
[Music]
now i was going to be a driver for the
cartel let's move out
but i had no idea what i had just signed
up for
the next day i drive to a warehouse in
the outskirts of el paso as an
undercover agent with the 90 kilos of
cocaine that were seized the day before
bella wapo was going to inspect it
i had backup
numerous d agents all over the place
at the same time i was very nervous and
unsure of what was going to happen
[Music]
we're waiting on a wapo to show up
i can see that rudy is definitely
nervous
the door opens and here comes el wapo
i could just feel the energy with this
guy and it was not a good
it's not a good thing
he's a cartel manager in a position of
power
i was intimidated at the same time i had
to go and do what i was supposed to do
i'll be driving
if he just looked at me and he goes how
do you know rudy
and i said well me really go back a
ways he had no idea rudy had betrayed
him
he's staring me up and down
he notices the gun under my belt
he says a pretty good size gun you got
there i said yeah and he goes let me see
it
and he starts looking at it inspecting
it
i was getting nervous
but all of a sudden he puts the gun in
my head and he asked me so tell me again
how you know rudy
i thought to myself only he's gonna blow
my brains out
so i just said hey listen
stop busting my balls
he cracked the smile and
lowered the gun and handed it back to me
inside i was fierce i want to get that
gun and shove it up
i love the coke
but i had to keep my cool
and continue with what we were going to
do
we unload the the cocaine and the whole
time wap was just standing there
watching us
my heart was racing
and i'm thinking okay never hit the
mother lode here
this was enough to arrest him
eventually he ended up saying want to
get to get out of here this thing will
be moving tomorrow
this is the opportunity that i wanted
okay i just pull out my gun
put your hands up where i can see them
he was furious
he wanted to kick my ass right there but
i knew i had the upper hand this time
[Music]
you